and i feel like you know now that i look
back on it a big
reason why i was so resistant against
the hadith y'all know why it was exactly
exact
and like bro the more that i like really
set with that and like i understood it
like i understood it 100
where it's like ah you know what
[Music]
hmm
we want to make this video today to talk
about ramadan
or more so the time after because that's
the time that we are
in and you know alhamdulillah we
made it we've hopefully experienced some
amazing things and hopefully cultivated
you know a deeper deen a deeper practice
and all that stuff but now now's the the
real test
that was when it's like supposedly uh
fire was telling me
that during ramadan uh shakedown and all
the [ __ ] dino locked up
and that supposedly after ramadan well
they ain't locked up no more
so it's like all right everything that
we cultivated within that month
now we're going to be tested and we're
going to see like okay are we
did we actually learn something did we
actually cultivate something
or was it just periodically for like
that one month
and we want to make this video to just
touch on these things and how we can
continue
to keep the things that we cultivated
for the long run
i mean obviously i'm a revert so i'm not
gonna know too much extensively
but the two brothers here will
definitely be able to go in further than
me
uh but yeah with that being said rami
what you got to say on the matter
well firstly i want to say that i think
that you know you can bring something to
the table i mean if i can't you know
this being your first actual ramadan i
think that
you know sheds light in a different way
or on some spots that you know i
couldn't really touch on myself
uh so i think you know your your
anecdotal experience masha'allah would
be you know crucial
for muslims we're born to islam and
reverts alike
but with me i would say that i heard
once a sign of an accepted ramadan and
accepted fasting and everything is
your bad habits that died stay dead and
your good habits that you created
um you know you keep them and maintain
them so things like you know if you're
praying sunnah prayers during ramadan
don't stop after ramadan if you're
reading the quran
during ramadan don't start don't sorry
don't stop afterwards
you should definitely start if you
haven't but uh don't stop in the quran
afterwards
basically saying uh the good that you
started to do in ramadan
uh don't stop it you know there is a
portion that you know
feels closer to allah because the gates
of jahannam are closed the gates of
jannah are open the shayateen like the
chiefs and the leaders they're all
they're locked up um and for that reason
you know it's a holiest month ramadan we
feel close to allah
but actually um it seems that the reason
we feel so close to allah
and the ummah as a whole is because
we're engaged in things that allah
made obligatory for us and we're doing
voluntary acts of good
allah says the most beloved acts of
worship are those which he made
obligatory
and the slave continues to get closer to
allah with voluntary acts of good until
allah begins to love him
or her and now what we see is that
that's exactly what people are trying to
do
during ramadan so if you continue that
you'll still have that feeling
as if it's ramadan even though it's not
maybe not exactly the same
but uh you know close enough continue to
fast um
uh for the month of like shawwal the the
six uh days and the three white days of
every month and
mondays and thursdays like the prophet
peace be upon him did and you will
inshallah continue to feel that
closeness to allah
because if you feel that you allah you
and allah drifted away
allah isn't moving so who's the one who
moved obviously you
how to get back on track by doing the
obligatory
and the sunnah and voluntary acts of
good until allah begins to love you
that's my two cents five i don't know if
you want to add anything to that
mashallah man that was perfect bro all
that all i wanted to add
was for me this is just what i do
regardless of missing any days of
fasting or not
i fast for a little bit longer after i
eat you know and
this is something i've been doing anyway
like even outside of ramadan throughout
the year
i'll do a couple days of like proper
ramadan style fasting dry fasting not
just intermittent right
and it just keeps me in that in that
state in that frame
especially right before ramadan i'll
fast a week before ramadan
just to kind of prep for it too and it
just helps me really stay in the game
and i agree with you bro habits that you
quit during ramadan
i found myself like like very easy to
keep them
and abstain from them after ramadan so
it's good to know that it's a good sign
that
i actually quit it bro yeah
alhamdulillah
bro so repeat those uh the sunnah
fasting yeah so for the sun there is
something called the three white days
which i believe is the 14th 15th
and 16th of every month and uh
mondays and thursdays those are when the
prophet saws would fast as sunnah
and there's actually a studies panel
that showed uh
that if a person fast two days a week is
like the most healthiest for them or
something like that i i don't remember
the study or anything but i remember
hearing that family
so if you guys interested look it up but
um yeah there's some notes fast mondays
and thursdays and then the three white
days of every month
so would it be a drive first on those
days
we'd be fasting as if you're fasting um
i believe in islam we only have dry
fasting
yeah okay okay that's interesting
that's interesting so question for the
both of you when
because y'all have been muslim
definitely for a lot
longer than i have but why y'all's lives
what has uh caused you to drift
in in terms of ramadan like after you
finish ramadan
and you've fallen back into like old
patterns of behavior
what has caused you to shift back into
these patterns
um why do you want to go first bro
straight up minus is not going to be as
long
as maybe rami's actually i don't know
how long
he's at it's gonna be but my answer's
sure bro when i have low iman
ramadan is just an event it's just a
month
of fasting it's just a month of
directions kind of like when you have
low iman
salah isn't connecting with allah and
worship it's more like
going through those movements and
getting that little you know
that two-second two-minute thing that
you got to do not really present you
know what i mean
so for me when i didn't have high man
forget after ramadan but ramadan itself
was just you know sometimes i
wouldn't really be fasting or i didn't
really take it seriously right
um it just it just was something that i
knew
i had to do i didn't really understand
the value i had no iman
so similarly when ramadan was done i was
just like whatever bro
until next ramadan yeah for allah but
that's the that's the mentality that i
had but once i really got into islam
it didn't matter like what it was i
didn't question things anymore because i
most of the things that allah tells us
to do i see the value
the 20 or 10 of things that i don't
really see the direct
you know cause and effect or direct
reasoning or understanding behind
i trust allah because the other 90 99
i'm literally able to see feel um
you know mental mentally like visualize
and like actually relate to
the effects that you know allah
guaranteed and promised us and willed
for us
but the little things like you know
don't do this don't do that that i'm
kind of like
not 100 with understanding why no man
it's all from allah
i'm i'm fully at the point where i know
that everything allah tells us to do is
for our own good
and i'm grateful that allah even gave us
the consciousness to like see these
blessings
just like mahdi said in that episode
i could relate to that so heavily man
that was actually going to be like the
first part of my answer
um the mentality you know looking at
ramadan
maybe not as just an event but looking
at ramadan as
this is the peak and then after that
it's
like once the 30th 30th night or the
last night ramadan is done it's like
it's like i regress all this instantly
it's like it's no longer ramadan which
means i'm not as good which means
i revert back to the state so the first
one is a mentality if you think that way
okay
you're not going to be any better than
you were before ramadan you're just
going to regress right away because
the way you're thinking secondly i would
say is um
if you do haram like if you're engaging
in sin
maybe because of that mentality or
whatever then it's going to drive you
further away from allah you're going to
feel like you don't want to pray you're
going to feel like you don't want to
fast you're going to feel like you don't
want to read quran
because it's it's this kind of cognitive
dissonance where
you you're doing things that muslims
should do and you're doing things that
muslims shouldn't do
and it's kind of like you you lean to
one side rather than the other
so i think those things are what really
kill
uh you know after ramadan or even during
ramadan
the mentality and if you go back to
haram i think that really ruins it for
people
um i think mentality is the worst one to
be honest because
you know if you have a bad mentality
then everything else is going to suck in
your life
if your mentality is kind of like on and
off
um sometimes you perform adam sometimes
you don't you always repent
what's what's what actually
allows one to have high iman
or low iman yeah so subhanallah high man
allah iman come and go to be honest you
don't really control it
but there are certain things you could
do so for example if your iman is low
the prosthetic a group of companions
came to him and they said you know we're
experiencing doubts horrible doubts of
kuffar
and the prophet said this is good news
because it's a sign of high iman
right so you know feeling certain ways
you're thinking certain ways doesn't
necessarily mean you have low iman
but i would say get your foundation down
in islam
understand the basics of islam and all
that if you don't and honestly just
studying islam
increases your iman just reading the
quran and increases your men just
reflecting on allah thinking about allah
just that mentality alone will increase
your iman so if you don't feel close to
allah
it's very possible that you should just
increase in certain things
or it may be that you're experiencing
some kind of doubt or something and if
it's emotional skepticism
you could dismiss it if it's a logical
dis uh skepticism you can deal with it
find the answer
and those are things that for me and you
know anecdotally speaking
i uh experienced and went through and uh
that's
how i would deal with it yeah
well how about you man how's your
ramadan how's afterwards how you feeling
about it
it's beautiful though it was
i i can't really put it into words dude
like i try in my videos that i've done
like the little series
yeah but i feel like it's so poor bro
like everything that i say i'm just like
ah bro it's so much more than that like
me putting into words is like me
dumbing it down to like something that's
just
a poor oh bro just a a
poor translation of what i experienced
yeah yeah so i don't know yeah bro
i'll go ahead before i even ask no bro i
was just gonna say i relate to that
that's why like
sometimes reading the translation of the
quran doesn't do it justice remotely
because
you're trying to translate something
that allah has revealed in arabic
in another language might not be one to
one where test fear might even be
a little more to the heart in those
circumstances so i can relate to you bro
yeah so a question that i have
for both of you let's say someone is
doing all these things
but their iman is still waving or
they're just having a hard time like
really getting into it and having that
faith like
what then and i'm not saying that i'm
experiencing that i'm just saying like
in general
yeah yeah if i don't recommend i
recommend uh
giving a roki a try there's no harm in
doing rokinon and
you know at the very least like one of
the signs of jin is that you'll get
phases of high iman and low iman and i'm
not talking about a gym possession like
a full-on possession there's levels to
possession that's
hadith right there's levels where i
forgot what it was it started with
l um there were two that started with l
one was like a mild possession like a
slight possession where they're just
you know in your presence there's
another one where there's multi jin and
they're they're actually entering you
there's ones that are fully
possessing you to the point where you
need you know rukia but i'm saying
there's no harm in doing
rookia right at the very least but one
of the signs is again
high and low iman because the gin they
don't want you to know that you're the
host they don't want you to know that
they're affecting you
right so essentially it tries to just
you know give you a social and to
mislead you to just
you know get to a point where you
basically are living in a haram life
and you rationalize it the only reason
you feel guilty
is because of this islam thing because
of allah right
so then you're like okay my problem's
clearly just islam
and you know it doesn't really make that
much sense anyway
i can't really prove lot anyway and
that's essentially where the downward
slip
slippery slope starts my invitation is
there's no harm
getting rokia right yeah yeah so how
like what rokia specifically like do
what they do on themselves would they go
to somebody
i would recommend doing it on yourself
because you know it's not going to be
the same
as you know somebody that's doing that
okay on you who specialize in that right
you can listen to quran or citations
right there's been people that listen to
quran recitations
and they don't feel anything but then
they go to you know get
you know rokia done and they have weird
symptoms they they fully you know get
possessed and these these specialists
they'll these moms they know how to like
you know hold you down they know exactly
what to do because they do this for a
living
may look you know protect all of them
and increase them and grant them the
highest levels of jannah bro because
this is not an easy thing to do this is
a very risky
and and ballsy thing which is you know
playing with with
smokeless fire to say the least yeah
it's kind of well
so you mean for the person to actually
go to a professional
not to get it done like themselves not
to like do a
youtube online yeah
that's not it okay yeah because you had
said for the person to do it themselves
but i think
you meant the other with your answer you
probably meant the other one you just
had a little slip of the tongue i mean
i like how the ginger slips right in
right pause
yourself by reciting quran yourself yeah
yeah just don't like look up a youtube
video or something
that might not allah adam but yeah
that's a good answer for
allah actually i don't even think about
you know jim possession or anything like
that subhanallah um
but i would say um actually fletcher
mentioned something called teschia to me
recently tuskey has like purification of
the soul
the etiquettes right and uh has a lot to
do with intention and purifying yourself
and your soul
your intentions towards allah the deen
the religion all of that so the only
other thing i can think of is that maybe
you're doing these actions but your
heart's not in the right place
so you need to do test kia and purify
yourself in your soul
and be as pure as possible when you do
these acts for the sake of allah because
then that's a sign
they're getting accepted because a
person can pray and be mindless in
prayer
are they going to feel the reward and
the benefits maybe not
uh so perhaps they just need to fix that
part of themselves and if they really
think they're being as sincere as
possible
and they still have some you know imam
problem they cannot pinpoint it
i would say just make dua to allah it
was i mean that should be number one
step number one to allah but in that
case all you can do is make dua to allah
and wait
i mean bro i mean bro i'm interested in
both
i'll probably do both yeah masha'allah
how do you do
the um the thing that fletcher mentioned
is is more of like a subject that you
learn right so taskia is is knowing that
you should love what allah loves and
hates what allah haste
hates right um your attitude towards the
quran your attitude towards the hadith
your attitudes towards allah attitude
towards the prophet
just your perspective your outlook and
the way you see things the way you learn
things and that you have to implement
what you learn and teach it um
afterwards insha allah so just certain
things like that your etiquettes
your manners your knowledge and your
attitude all
kind of go under this purification of
the heart because once you
perfect these things or get them to a
high level insha allah
the way your heart is you know is a lot
more content as a as a person
anywhere so is is this something is
there a specific way to do this or is
this something that someone just kind of
like
has to go about it in their own manner
um well i mean it would
most likely be uh it's like studying it
reading a book
like i learned it in my class at yd1
they uh teach it
in both levels of it we just finished
with alhamdulillah
and uh so you can have a teacher you can
read a book on it you can watch a video
on it
um or you can research it yourself
yo guys let me let me slip something
else in right now real quick
while we were talking about all this i
forgot we were recording
was that just me no not me too me too ah
i definitely forgot we're recording it
was very very nice it was gonna flow it
was natural right
yeah um
[Music]
it's beautiful that like you mentioned
that man and
like voila or during ramadan man like
y'all y'all know like before ramadan
i was kind of like just kind of iffy
about the hadith
i didn't speak very much about the uh
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
it's not that i like saw anything bad it
was just like
i don't know like i i didn't click
it didn't click the way that the quran
had clicked
and like i just not all that these made
sense it's just
not all of it clicked and it's like i i
don't know but i didn't want to like
idolize
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and it's like bro during ramadan
bro the hadees
subhanallah we're going to say the east
click and
row and um dude like
i i before ramadan
i don't think i had um a 100
trust and faith
in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
and like during ramadan like it was like
a complete shift where it's like
there was one day like i have to pray
well i was like you know what like
i believe i believe it a hundred percent
like i trust
i trust in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and brother like the moment
that that
happened you know what i'm not even
gonna say i'm not even gonna say what
happened
i'm just gonna say that that is what
happened
during ramadan like now i have that
trust and um
and yeah the hadith click so
allah that's a beautiful thing man i'm
going to send this clip to brother
fareed inshallah
them and all that
yeah man i'm the liar but you you're
right man it's like
the moment that that like you start to
believe in that more like
it i don't i'm trying to put into words
here
i'm doing a bad job but it is like i can
say
i can honestly say from direct
experience because it's only been a few
weeks
that like when that happened like my
iman just like
instantly skyrocketed and it's like
before
like yeah i believed in the quran i was
reading the quran
i was doing my prayers but it's like man
like when you have that trust in that
actual prophet of islam
when like you look at the beasts and
like they click
now and like you're seeing them and like
it all it's all like aligning and making
sense like
something like that something like uh
they won't be you know true believers
until they love you like the prophet
said
more than themselves and their in their
families
he responded to the prophet and he was
like listen i love you
but i don't love you more than myself
and then later he left
and he came back and he's like you know
you know rasool allah
isn't there a verse in the quran that
says anyone that doesn't follow the
prophets of islam is not from the woman
yeah yeah yeah right and and like the
the whole way that we got the quran
was through the same means that we get
at least authentic ones right it's the
same chain of transmission
right so for me it's more like the
authentic hadith
that completely aligned with the quran
cool follow because the quran is the
actual word of allah right
the things that can neither align nor
disalign right
for example things that are not directly
in the quran
follow these because they're so
authentic but these aren't these
little trivial things aren't like
necessitating you
causing rifts in the ummah and
disagreeing with your own brothers
but that's just my opinion right follow
it but like
you can't you don't need to like you
know create more division in the omaha
because of this
and things that are not really even in
line with the quran like whatever bro
like chicken cool you know
i live with love bro chicken is good you
know
but there's people here that are like oh
there's no music in the quran
so i'm going to listen to music bro
there's clearly hadith
written on hadith on deep like people
just don't accept it
and i feel like you know now that i look
back on it a big reason
why i was so resistant against
the hadees y'all know why it was exactly
exact
and like bro the more that i like really
sat with that and like i understood it
like i understood it 100
it's like ah you know what
it is haram to strike your brother in
the face
and i've said this before i wouldn't
want to strike romney or
fire in the face out of anger bro out of
anger
now again i sat with it and i was like
you know what for training purposes
it makes sense that it would be uh
permissible but then
for professional purposes like if i'm
just doing it for money
i'm doing it for like a career like okay
well it kind of gets
to be a little bit more than uh training
purposes at that point because there are
other ways
to go about training it and bro like the
more that i just
understood it and like put myself aside
i started to realize like ah this
emotional response that i had
was what was causing this uh
this rift in between all the other
hadiths
where it's like man like once i put that
aside like it's like ah well okay i
could see this
i could see that and it all just starts
clicking and coming together where it's
like dude
the most authentic hadees can almost be
seen
as the truth if not be truth now you
know allah whoever
right allah we don't know that but it's
like
you can clearly connect it with the
quran
and it's like then you have the other
hadiths which um
they might not be as authentic but
there's a lot of wisdom behind
you know what i mean it's like even then
like it's
it's still something that can uh
progress you
in your practice in your deen
yeah i agree bro but these rejections
are just
to me people are either arrogant or
ignorant bro and i like to give people
the benefit of the doubt at least the
first time
so that they're ignorant to me right i
don't want to see
anyone is ill informed or you know
anything like that so i'm just gonna say
they're uninformed
right but again everything with islam
that happens in steps bro you made a
video yourself on your main channel but
self-improvement happens in steps and i
think when you iman it's the same thing
like
you're a man's not going to be on 10 the
day you say your shahada
right but you're gonna if your heart is
pure and you truly want to
improve your life and come close to your
creator your master
if you take the steps and you just be
patient with the prop
the process bro then we watched that
video like yesterday or two days ago
that was like
um whenever you're you make a little
issue or a little problem like bigger
than it is
allah is going to give you bigger trials
and tribulations yeah
right to patience is one of our greatest
virtues as an ummah
is true right so you can even
extrapolate that to uh
you know the ayah in the quran
no one goes to hell without truly
deserving right and these people are
definitely going to go to hell these
transgressors so just got to be uh be
patient
in the meantime yeah and the more i
think about it i think there should be
an episode on youtube and yeah i was
thinking the same thing i was like dude
let's just throw this on youtube this is
a good episode
it's a good episode bro just guys if you
made it this far
write down um
allowing her pick it since he was
basically the star of the show
but once you guys put the hashtag down
that he's gonna tell you
uh yeah this was supposed to be a
patreon video but we made this into a
youtube video
hashtag er emotional resistance
oh e er i thought you said eat hard and
i was like
yeah i was thinking deep hard
pause bro you got that nasty mind right
now boy
stuff for a lot listen
the more that i think about it now like
the people who reject habits
it has to be because of emotional
resistance yeah
yeah what other reason could it be like
they they want to say and listen i'm
gonna i'm gonna speak you
because i feel like i was i was getting
close to that point
you know i'm i'm not gonna reject it
but at the same time i wasn't accepting
it so i was very close i was like
borderline uh i guess you guys would
call it uh
quranis is that what they call
themselves yeah
i didn't believe it but it's like dude
it was just the emotional resistance
because one of them didn't sit right
with me so then because one of them
didn't survive with me
i closed myself off to all the rest of
them and then even more
like started showing up that didn't sit
right with me but it's like the moment
that it's like i
fully understood this one that i had
emotional resistance to
and i opened up to that one then all the
other ones that i started feeling
emotional resistance who just
faded away and i started opening up to
each one of them
allah man i just want to offer even more
respect to you masha'allah because
that is the heart like so that is such a
difficult thing to do
to remove your emotions from something
especially something like your
your belief right to remove yourself
from it completely and just look at it
for the sake of allah first very
difficult thing to do and i'm there's no
doubt in my mind that
probably majority of our viewers and
even myself sometimes
i have like struggle with it a lot it is
a very difficult thing to do so may
allah reward you and bless you immensely
may allah prioritize you
in the way that you prior to it
prioritized him
i mean one of the greatest biases is the
thing that we always talk about the
greatest problem you could have is not
knowing right
most cognitive biases operate you know
in a subconscious level meaning you're
not aware that you have these biases
oftentimes when people even call you out
on it because they're not in your head
they're not you
they could see it objectively we don't
want to admit it we're just like nah but
what do you mean
you don't see it like that or maybe you
know you're not smart enough to see it
that way
yeah but oftentimes like you know other
people see it and they're telling you
for a reason
i completely forgot what i was gonna say
but we got four minutes
i say we just we just talk about some uh
i think this episode is more gonna be
outpatient so i'm gonna i'm gonna title
it something about patience and
stuff like that so yeah anything else
what we spoke about in the beginning
about the ramadan yeah yeah
that was the main topic yeah that was
but then now we're all brought this
we could we could put both you know yeah
we'll figure that out but
yeah but i have one question for you
guys before we got this one
what helps you guys stay patient amidst
the chaos
[Music]
on hell let you go first man
patient against the chaos well chaos in
like what situation
any difficulty anything anything
anything well pause pause because i
remember what i was going to say before
so let me say that first and then i'll
answer all right so
the thing that i was going to say you
you know romney you were saying that
like i i
put my emotion aside and was able to see
it for what it really wasn't put allah
first
and like bro i'm not gonna lie this
didn't happen overnight
this definitely took the entire ramadan
and um
it even took a little bit more it even
took during eight as well like when
fired had sent this video i think it was
yesterday
in the video it has said um if you're
looking to be happy in this life well
then you're looking in the wrong place
yeah or like you're in the wrong place
for that and it's like bro like i really
thought about that i'm like
like we we are born and then we die
that's a direct example of how temporary
our life is here
yes right everything is impermanent in
this life
we feel happy that's very impermanent
right we feel sad that's impermanent
anything we feel
anything we experience is all temporary
so i was like dude
if you if you really are happy
enough everything could happen nothing
could happen and you will be happy
but that's not the case right we live in
this dunya it's all temporary and then
on top of that everything that's dunya
is conditional
meaning that everything needs something
like i can't say i love you
without there being a condition behind
it and if i say i love you for the sake
of allah there's still a condition
behind it
yeah only the creator can actually love
you
without anything unconditional right
so if everything has a condition then
for me to say i
am happy that's a lie because it means i
need something in order
for me to be happy something needs to
happen i need to experience something i
need to have something i need to finish
something
something has to happen in order for me
to be happy and if it doesn't well then
i'm not happy and even if it does happen
i'm only happy for this much time before
i need to give myself another hit of
this drug to be happy again
yeah um it was like brothers
go back go ahead and go ahead no i was
just like have you heard of this quote
this too shall pass yeah
it has two it has two meanings one is if
you're going through something bad don't
worry
pass but if you're also going through
something good it's not it's not forever
it's temporary
i know it's temporary yeah so
the whole point i'm trying to make here
is that because this is all temporary
because we live in this dunya like for
me
to hold on to my emotions and be like
you know what
i'm going to not i'm not going to accept
the
hadees but i'm not going to reject them
i'm just going to be kind of like a
bystander
because of an emotional response well
that that would be extremely selfish
for me to do because what
what's the what's the point me saying
that uh mma gives me freedom mma makes
me happy mma
uh makes me less stuck in my head it's
like okay but that's temporary
yeah at some point bro at some point i
could get in the accident
i could be paralyzed and then i can't do
mma at all
then what then what am i gonna say bro
so it's like i had the choice like
humble myself
or get humbled at some point or another
and it's like dude i'm choosing to
humble myself
because like i still want to practice
mma but i don't want it to be
the end-all be-all i don't want it to be
like that main thing where it's like you
know what my main thing should be allah
because this is all temporary
and you know what if if i have to give
up being
professional
so what like what what is that in the
grand scheme of it
and it's like dude at the end of the day
like i don't know the unseen
i don't know what's gonna happen so
allah might have it in my plan still to
be professional
just like allah had it in habib's plans
you know we don't know allah's plan
that's the greatest thing
it's like dude some dude ass habib
if uh if he thought that allah would be
um
happy with what he's doing and bro he
was straight up
honest he's like i don't think he'll be
happy with what i'm doing
he was straight up on his but he knew
exactly what he was doing
but you know what for some reason it was
in allah's plan
for him to be in those moments
at those exact time frames
i mean guys like look at what happened
with him and conor mcgregor look at
like the huge shift that that it had on
so many
individuals in this world and not just
individuals but on
on the conor mcgregor himself like look
how humble this dude has become i'm not
gonna lie he's still got an ego
but look how much more humble he is now
after
getting destroyed by habit
bro real quick i'll put i put my video
off because my phone's charging because
i'm at one percent
oh yeah that's fine but yeah i agree bro
get you know humble yourself first or
get humbled
yeah so the question you had asked i'mma
let romney answer because i talked a
little bit too much um
about staying patient yes
i just wanted to clarify i think angel
was asking uh
what are you talking about in in regards
to
you know when you know are you referring
to patients what i'm talking about
isn't when you're amidst the chaos of
your iman you know may allah got us from
that bro
if you're having you know turbidities in
your iman that's that's deeper issue i'm
talking about
you know chaos in your dunya
so just day to day trials and
tribulations how do you stay patient
both of you um you know
when you mention patients it reminded me
of something i heard once um about what
imam al-ghazali
said and he said that like it's so deep
he said that patience is just gratitude
during tough times
and gratitude is just patience during
good times
and subhanallah he was trying to say
that they're interchangeable uh so think
about like this
being patient the best way to be patient
is to
say alhamdulillah for what you still
have and say alhamdulillah for every
condition
and to be grateful for what allah has
given you and what allah has has
you know the position allah has put you
in life and the ability to stay grateful
during tough times results in patience
the ability to endure a lot longer and
he said that subhanallah gratitude is
patience during good times and it's like
how do you how are you patient during
good times it's like
when things are good for x amount of
time sometimes you become stale and
that's
that's the time it's easiest to fall
like angel always says you know the well
what's the saying the uh the fall always
comes before
oh i i know what you're saying but i
don't think that applies to this one
are you sure because that that's all
that has to do with arrogance
yeah but i mean arrogance is just a lock
up the fall comes
right after pride or something like that
yeah yeah and the reason the reason i
believe it connects is because
like the quranic opposite of of uh
arrogance is gratitude
allah because when iblees fell and he
became arrogant
he wasn't grateful to allah
i forgot the the verse i mentioned that
but um
uh allah mentions that he was ungrateful
right
or that he wasn't being grateful to
allah so i think there were multiple
verses
in there yeah so um subhanallah
if you're in a good time you have to be
patient knowing that this may be the
peak this may be
all the best you're going to get in this
life and that jannah
is has better and you just have to live
life um
because some people spend a lot when
they hit you know the top they may not
have
you know a lot to work for or towards
and a lot of them become very intolerant
you know with the people around them and
all this stuff and it's like
a lot of them end up losing that
patience and they end up losing their
amen and losing themselves because they
weren't able to stay patient
um even in good times subhanallah
sometimes the test of abundance is
harder than the test
of um scarcity
because when you're living in abundance
you it's so easy to forget
um and that's when you stop being
grateful to allah because you couldn't
stay
resilient and patient even during the
good time
so go on you were saying something uh
to me and rami before we hit record
today
that we we haven't been doing something
much lately
um you want to see what it is so the
viewers can know
why just just cause bro
i said we haven't been talking yeah we
haven't been talking much right aside
from like
recording episodes because yo everyone
here is probably like bro what are you
guys talking about you guys did daily
uploads for like 10 days
he's he's referring to us just chopping
it up without recording
right but today it kind of felt like we
did both
and it was like the perfect blend where
i didn't feel like we were recording at
all
yeah i feel like it started feeling like
we were recording more like once you
kind of brought the awareness over the
fact that
we weren't so focused on the fact that
we were recording
[Music]
this is what happens when you mix
business with uh
would you say casual personal life
personal life yeah
um but bro for me business is my
personal life so
it is what it is boy if you guys made it
this far hashtag
home base if you want to see more
episodes of just
your boys at t3m no guests no filters no
edits
masha allah yeah but that's all i have
rami i know anything else
that's all i got
do you do you want to answer the your
own question
do you want me to answer that or do you
feel like romney gave uh i want i want
you to answer and you're substantial
bro just being on d but i could say so
much but
being on dean is the only true way
to handle the chaos because like look i
could be
here and be like yo you got to meditate
or no you got to be sure in yourself as
a man or as a woman
it's like bro like i'm sorry but like
any of this other stuff like your ego is
gonna get fixed in
and once your ego gets mixed in like
dude you know how fragile
you is so it's only a matter of time
before the ego
uh just gets hurt and breaks and when it
breaks like yeah well you're not going
to be real
you're not going to be calm in that
chaos
you're going to be real chaotic
yes my bro perfect example perfect
example let's say
you're with your girl with your wife
okay let's say your wife starts acting
up
if you're showing yourself as a man
and you meditate or you do whatever you
do when you calm you you're on your
purpose you do your thing
right if she acts up
maybe the first several times you'll be
able to remain calm
and uh put her in her place and
just kind of make sure everything's good
right but it's gonna get to a point
where it's like maybe
one day you might be slightly off
maybe maybe you know something happened
in your work
maybe you just you kind of been slacking
off for the past
week or maybe you know just maybe
you've been feeling a little insecure of
yourself
just that little slit will be enough
for your ego to just shatter and then
once your ego shatters
you're going to break your frame get
into an
argument with your girl and then y'all
will probably have
more issues than anything right y'all
will be arguing for like a very long
time
and like you you're going to disrupt
this whole
um masculine feminine role masculine
feminine frame
and it's it might be something that you
might not be
able to recover from you know allah
knows best i love whoever
but it's like dude if you're on deep it
doesn't matter if
your work is going slightly bad doesn't
matter if you feel slightly insecure of
yourself doesn't matter
if um you've been slipping up and all
this other stuff like bro if
if you're on dean and you always put
allah first
your girl comes to you and she's acting
up
bro who are you gonna feel you you can
feel her or you're gonna feel allah
you're gonna fear the relationship
going to waste you guys getting divorced
you're going to feel a lot what are you
going to feel here so like i feel like
the dean
keeps you in check that's like okay
there are
priorities here and i'm going to act
accordingly
bro that's why i turn on my camera as
you're saying that i'm just like well we
got to throw in another hashtag
hashtag relatable if you could relate to
that if you have lives
or well you can't really have anything
other than life maybe you have a husband
you know for women if you're a woman
yeah it only if you're a woman bro we
you know we don't we don't do that that
over here
but uh if you got a wife or a husband
how many of you can relate i have to
turn on my camera because bro
100 as facts you know um keeping
staying on beam is the only way
yep rami relate no relate
um you're not exactly married but i can
definitely relate something i know he's
coming from we're just with people
just in general yeah 100 um actually i
made a video recently you know five
i think it was five tips for life
something like that not recently
i made it was it on youtube yeah it's on
youtube
and uh one of the uh tips was something
i learned from angel be present
uh and something i learned from islam
and be conscious of allah
because being present in the moment
allows you to you know know what's going
on
uh around you but being conscious of
allah know tells you exactly how to act
because when you remember allah is
watching you what your actions are good
and the way you do those actions are
good so what you're saying to someone is
is
it's authentic it's true for the sake of
allah and the way you're saying is also
for the sake of allah so you're not
coming off as like a
uh some lunatic or something losing his
head top thinking
you know he's doing the right thing so
uh a hundred percent
bro and it goes to show like what you're
saying like
if if if you're seeing allah if you have
the demon process if
you focus on love like you're going to
come from that place
you know like you may be hurt right what
this person said may have hurt you
yeah but you're going to come from a
place of like you know what
the creator's watching you right now
yeah
like what i say i am liable for
what i do i am live before so if i act
up here
i'm the one that's gonna pay that
consequence not you
the facts bro as you were saying that
thing about you know people that are
that could relate with their wives or
spouses about that
it's not just that but i feel like as
men we have that pressure because
at the end of the day when it's kyama
when it's you know we're
answering allah we are held accountable
for everyone in our house
right yes our our spouses our wives
they're
they're they're going to be responsible
what happens in the house like you know
they usually the house is straight and
everything but we are going to be held
accountable
for our family you know we are the
guardian we are the wali
you know of our wives bro so at the end
of the day
if we're not looking out for the family
chance is not
somebody else has to it's going to
crumble and most of the time
women don't really want that pressure
bro and they don't need to a lot
ordained for us that pressure so don't
worry about it
yeah that is true yeah
and and before any chick tries to um
say anything and you know i'll rephrase
that i'll rephrase that so if
a woman is feeling offended by me saying
chick i'll rephrase that
all right if any woman is uh
not taking this so well are you she
might be saying something oh well if
if i'm acting up or if i'm upset well
the man should be listening and
listen all right when a woman acts up
when you act up as a woman
do you want a man that's just going to
listen to you
and basically say yes ma'am yes ma'am
yes baby yes baby okay baby okay i'll do
this for you baby oh i'm sorry baby
do you want this do you want the pleaser
who's just trying to please you or do
you want a man
who's gonna be daddy
who you know and again if that offends
you
uh i'll rephrase it i'll rephrase it for
you
do you want a man who's going to be
robber no no that's the same thing but
in spanish come on man
do you want a man that's actually going
to hold it down
and none is he going to look at you he's
going to listen to you
but he's going to make all your troubles
seem like
nothing and all the chaos that you are
experiencing
the mental or emotional chaos he's going
to put all that to rest
and bring you back to your center yeah
do you want that what do you want to do
that's just trying to please you
i mean come on now yeah
one thing i want to strong men bro we're
running out of hashtags for this bro
what is it
guys let's wrap this up bro because i
know let's go cook something fire fire
we i'm not fighting but uh romney what
are you gonna say yo just gonna add on
really quickly a lot of them
um are gonna assume like worst case
scenario they're gonna assume something
like um
but what if he you know does something
wrong what if he wrongs me
uh what about islam you heard about that
what's up what about it
it's called it's called what about ism
is this fundamental
uh flaw that everyone has they think
about the worst case scenario like
oh what if the man actually can't
provide
and the woman has to do this because
basically he's like paralyzed
like bro you guys are bringing like the
weirdest like
worst case scenarios that don't happen
like 99
that's had a lot so i'll mention this so
they don't fall into
what about ism is that what it's called
but a lot of them gonna be like
well if he abuses me neglects me harms
me throws me in the street
and and i come home i expect him to at
least say sorry you know i don't want a
man he's not able to
say sorry that's not what he's saying
that's not what he's saying it's it's
when you're acting up
when you're out of place when you're uh
transgressing
or even when you're not yes yes
um it's not like when he beats you up
and then we'll apologize
nobody nobody take that or even if he
beats you up
oh no no no let me add on to my example
because i feel like i
i left out a part so i talked about a
dude like
basically saying please and like trying
to please her but like i forgot to
mention that
there's steps that happens before a man
gets to that point see like a man will
start
from a proper state and if he doesn't
have that [ __ ] why he doesn't have that
feel of allah
if he's acting from his ego like i said
it'll be a while
he might be able to hold it down a few
times but
there's going to be that one day where
something's off and then he's going to
slip
and when he slips the frame is broken
and when the frame is broken again it
may never be
uh reformed and if it's never reformed
then it ends up in the man taking
the feminine frame and the woman taking
the masculine frame and then the man is
basically here saying
please please please begging the woman
trying to please her
and not wanting to handle with any
confrontation
you know so had to clear that up there
masha allah
all right all right guys i'm not saying
anything bro this is this is it bro
we're gonna we're never gonna stop
talking about it
all right
special announcement only for those that
made this part one
me and angel have new mics and
they will be in a few episodes maybe in
one or two episodes insha'allah
number two i am launching my own first
youtube channel
you know i don't want any of you guys
say anything else pertaining to that but
if you made it this far
uh maybe right hashtag fire's channel
but that's it
that's all you guys are gonna know for
now oh i got something to add too
i got something there too insha allah
i will be re-releasing
my coaching program for self-improvement
so if there's anyone out there
who's trying to go deeper into the
self-improvement
hit me up i will leave the information
in the description box below
and uh yeah inshallah inshallah
inshallah that being said may allah
bless you all if you made it this far
this was a prime episode
prime episode
masha allah i'm not going to add another
hashtags panel we have five or six so
with that being said may allah bless you
all remember all the hashtags if you
write all of them you are definitely an
og so may allah bless you
and with that being said
assalamu alaikum
[Music]
so what if you pray five times a day so
what if you give x amount of uh
so what if you pray x amount of nothing
actually we need to humble ourselves and
remind ourselves that
us praying that many times a day us
giving said amount
ask praying extra salawat that in itself
is a blessing from allah in the first
place having instilled it
in our mind to want to do it
we need to thank allah not just for
being able to give
we need to thank him for having given us
the consciousness
to want to give in the first place
because even that is from him
[Music]
um